I am pet valleca with reason TV today
I'll be speaking with ABC News
correspondent my former boss John
stofflet
stick around and hear Stalin's take on
bailouts Bush Obama media bias and how
he collaborated with Drew Carey and
recent TV to produce his new ABC News
special [ __ ] in America something
that it's sir to get your blood pumping
what do you think of this bailout mania
that's sweeping the country I think it's
disgusting in that they keep saying
everybody agrees that we have to bail
these people out and we have to have the
feds spend trillions of your tax dollars
guaranteeing this and that or the
economy would collapse or it's already
collapsing and it's just so
irresponsible they've got a thirty five
trillion dollar Medicare liability
already that they're not facing and now
they're gonna throw more trillions of
dollars at this to stop this recession
like we're not allowed to experience any
pain in America there are recessions
there are booms and busts bubbles have
to pop well speaking of booms and busts
there was the tech bubble and it
exploded you know eight nine years ago
nobody got bailed out then why not good
question a different attitude now in
this case there are smart people may
look like Hank Paulson making me
argument this is different you've got
the credit lock the whole system is at
stake it's possible but global warming
being a disaster is possible too and
what I've learned over 30 years of
consumer reporting is that the people
closest to the problem panic and when
they panic that is an invitation for
government to get bigger it's like any
it's not war is the friend of the state
it's any crisis is the friend of the
state and the mad cow doctors were
convinced we were all gonna have holes
in our brains and anybody who ate meat
was at risk of these horrible diseases
the y2k technicians or convinced all the
planes were gonna crash now it's Wall
Street investment bankers who are
closest to it
unfortunately are allowed to spend
trillions of our dollars in their panic
do you think some of them may be a
lesson that the tech people might have
learned is that they should have spent
less time improving their products and
more time spending money on lobbyists in
Washington well I hope not I think it's
not an accident that the Microsoft and
Google and all that were developed in
the two capitals farthest from
Washington DC but now they spend money
sucking up to Washington that's it's not
a good thing for our prosperity what's
sort of precedent or lesson does it tell
someone who maybe is a responsible
renter or someone who pays his mortgage
on time that the people who were perhaps
irresponsible we're biting off more than
they could chew because there's a lot of
renters who would have liked to buy
during the upswing they decided they
looked at the books and they said hey it
doesn't make sense for me so I'm gonna
continue to rent there's a lot of people
who are paying their mortgages on time
and yet the federal government is coming
in and renegotiating lower payments for
people who maybe were dishonest what do
you think about that what lesson is that
well that's the moral hazard and we all
know about that it clearly if you reward
your responsible behavior you'll get
more bad bad behavior but I don't know
that that many people actually say I'll
over invest because I know I can get a
bailout at the other end I just think it
does create a culture which makes the
bubble a bigger bubble all this support
for we have to have more people owning
homes and Fannie and Freddie will
guarantee these mortgages encouraged a
crazier bubble and now you have to let
the bubbles pop you have to find the
floor let's let's take a quick look back
at the Bush years Reason magazine and
others have documented how spending has
exploded to historic proportions
regulations have ballooned and yet
people look back on the Bush years and
say it's a failure of free-market
policies what do you say to that I say
[ __ ] everybody says see your
libertarian ideas they're wrong and this
proves it well first of all there was no
real deregulation glass-steagall was
done under Clinton and he rightly
defends that and the banks that had more
options under glass-steagall were not
the ones necessarily that got into
trouble and under Bush the regulators
have added more of a spiderweb of little
rules to our lives more pages of rules
than any administration ever and more
the cost of regulation has gone up more
under Bush than any president before and
yet because of the bad media coverage
and the assumption about Republicans or
the free marketeers that supposedly were
in charge people think it was less a
fair now I'm sure there are some people
that regulatory agencies least I hope
they are who said you know a lot of
these rules are bad and we're gonna be
less aggressive about them under Bush
but that's not what caused this bubble
the bubble was government's angling more
and more you're you're discriminating
against poor people you're racist lend
to more people
that's not deregulation what are your
greatest hopes and fears for the Obama
years ah my fear is that they'll spend
us all into bankruptcy and it will be
like the people were in the Weimar
Republic where they're running around
with wheelbarrows full of cash because
inflation is so bad or in like Zimbabwe
today because 35 trillion in the hole
for just Social Security and Medicare
they won't have the guts to raise taxes
well maybe they will but they won't
really be able to raise taxes enough to
pay for Social Security and Medicare
because you'd have to take just about
all people made and that would totally
destroy the economy they won't cut the
programs cuz we older people want the
best of medical care and we're gonna
demand it and the politicians can't say
no to anybody so I fear they're just
gonna print more money what about the
other side that hope my hope is that hey
Nixon what the China maybe Obama will be
financially responsible and maybe he'll
do the things that the reason things
should be done like legalized drugs and
prostitution and and the criminalizing
of behavior between consenting adults
well what about the drug policy is you
there there's some signals that Obama's
giving that he's gonna soften on that
front things perhaps like medical
marijuana
well I hope he does the signals I've
heard is that he was appointing a
hardliner they had the drug policy
office so that was not a good sign I
don't know I think Hayek called it a
fatal conceit to think you can plan an
economy and I think it's also a fatal
conceit to predict what these
politicians will do is the mainstream
media biased I know you get this
question a lot but people want to know
what do you think about that yes is it
the fish don't feel the water kind of
thing or is it just that Liberty itself
isn't tv-friendly like you can pass a
minimum wage law and go interview the
happy employee at Burger King who just
had her wage boosted but you can't
interview the person who doesn't know
that he wasn't gonna get hired that's
part of it it's certainly hard to show
the people who are hurt by a government
program that takes two cents from
everyone or prevents a job from being
created you can't take a picture of that
but that's not just television I think
Liberty intuitively is hard to get
intuitively the minimum wage makes sense
we want to help poor people raise the
minimum wage it's hard for people to
understand how that hurts people but
plus there is just the basic political
bias that the people with whom I work
read the New York Times in the
Washington Post and that's their world
everybody around them agrees with them
they're all lean left and they think
that's the middle what do you think of
this whole internet thing you think
it'll catch on that's really made a lot
at least the internet showed people that
there was a liberal media now the public
at least knows that ABC NBC CBS lean
left
CNN especially on this NBC because it
gets talked about on the Internet and
now thanks to finally deregulation Fox
TV they have an alternative but I made a
lot of money you made some - in the days
from the days when government monopoly
limited the number of TV stations the
broadcast networks lobbied Congress and
say if you allow cable to come in
everywhere then poor people who can't
afford cable will be deprived of free TV
so there were five channels that helped
me make more money but certainly wasn't
fair
it's far better that we have 150
channels now you've defined yourself
before as a libertarian someone who is
fiscally free-market and liberal on
social issues do you think that
worldview is gaining an influence or
going the other way I don't know I mean
it's easier for me now because there's
more point of view and TV so that makes
me think at least now people know these
ideas deserve a place at the table
that's why ABC lets me do it but are we
winning as this move toward more
spending makes me think
you